Water
Earth
Fire
Air
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new avatar the last
airbender netflix series
mike and brian the creators made a big
announcement this morning about the
project so i'll explain
what it means what's going to be
happening with the show and what other
avatar stuff they're working on right
now
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will
continue to do avatar the last airbender
videos for the animated series for the
live action series that they're doing
right now
but i'll number these as we go along
just to stay organized so starting with
the big stuff first
mike and brian who have been working on
the new live action avatar the last
airbender series for netflix
since 2018 just announced just dropped a
bomb
that they have left the project as of
june this past year
but it's not all bad because they said
they both had plans to continue working
on new avatar stuff
in the avatar universe i'll explain what
that means in a second too after i
explain their big statements
so for those of you hoping for a new
animated avatar the last airbender
series with a different avatar
things are still looking good down the
road they both posted lengthy statements
about why they chose to leave the new
netflix live-action project and what
happened to lead up to that decision
so for those of you who are wondering
why they've continued to be so quiet
while we haven't gotten any updates
about the series the past few years
about casting
or release date or episodes or teasers
this kind of explains why
so we'll just read their statements then
i'll explain what it all means for the
new series because you kind of have to
read between the lines to understand
what they're really trying to say
the things that they really fought with
netflix about because they can't get too
public with it just because of legal
reasons so brian starts by saying
michael dimartino and i recently chose
to leave netflix's live-action
adaptation of avatar the last airbender
the series he and i created together in
we will have no involvement in the
project moving forward
this is probably the most difficult
decision i've ever had to make but there
is no doubt in my mind it was absolutely
the right choice
when netflix brought me on board to run
this series alongside mike two years ago
they made a very public promise to
support our vision
unfortunately there was not a follow
through on that promise
though i got to work with some great
individuals both on netflix's side in
our own
small side of development team the
general handling of the project
created what i felt was a negative and
unsupportive
environment to be clear this was not a
simple matter of us not getting our way
mike and i are collaborative people we
did not need all the ideas to come from
us
as long as we felt like those ideas were
in line with the spirit and integrity of
avatar
we would have happily embraced them
however we ultimately came to the belief
that we would not be able to
meaningfully guide the direction of the
series
though i am profoundly disappointed by
how things turned out there are
wonderfully talented people who are
still working on the series
some of whom mike and i personally hired
and got to know during our time on the
project
we worked very hard together towards a
shared dream of how special this
adaptation
could be and i want to see them employed
and i hope that they get the chance to
do their best work on the series
perhaps the team that remains might
still be able to make something fans of
the original
and the entirely new audience can enjoy
i will continue to be deeply involved in
the avatar universe telling the stories
my partner and i
want to tell in a way that we want to
tell them i will put my time
energy and talents towards the projects
that give me the most fulfillment
in where i am afforded trust and respect
life is too short to do otherwise
signed brian konietzko so what does that
all mean reading between the lines
brian's statement lists
slightly different reasons for leaving
the project than mike's does
brian is making it sound like they felt
like they weren't in charge of the
project anymore and netflix didn't want
to do things the way that they wanted to
do them
and had some disagreements about
creative direction and how they actually
produced the series
in the way he talks about it just makes
it sound like netflix wasn't honoring
their creative choices for the series
that doesn't explain whether or not
netflix disagreed with the cast that
mike and brian wanted or
maybe they wanted a more americanized
version because when they first
announced that they were doing a new
live action avatar the last airbender
series
brian was super clear that he wanted to
do a retelling of the
original animated series but make it way
more authentic to the original cultures
that it was based on
mostly asian i've always thought of the
water tribe though as being based on
inuit cultures
but the fire nation the earth kingdom
the air nomads are all based on
different types of asian cultures
it's totally possible that netflix just
wanted avatar but making it stranger
things like the way the kids 11 also
bald hero with special powers blew up in
popularity and now that that show's
getting ready to end
netflix wants a new version of that with
another franchise
and even if you've only watched a couple
episodes of the original animated avatar
the last airbender
even though it follows around a group of
children or kids for the most part
teenagers around the world
it in no way gives off any kind of
stranger things vibe
at all also recently there was a report
that netflix was aggressively looking to
create its own huge
franchise like star wars or the marvel
cinematic universe
something that could go on for forever
and yes the avatar series mythology
allows you to do that
through different avatars a new one
being born when the previous one dies
but it sounds like mike and brian
probably didn't want to give this new
live-action avatar the last airbender
series the marvel treatment and just use
it to set up a billion other spin-offs
in sequel or prequel series
the other major disagreements that most
people have when they leave projects
like this in real high profile ways
is over budgets being too small and
production schedules being too quick
they announced the project back in 2018
when they did that netflix created a
landing page
on the platform that listed a 2020
release date
so it sounds like they wanted to get the
series out super quickly
obviously we know things didn't go down
that way also right now in 2020 being
a really terrible year mike and brian
imply that because of what's going on
with the virus it created some
insurmountable
practical challenges for the production
and they just couldn't come to terms
with netflix on it
also if you've seen any of netflix's
previous live-action anime adaptations
they have not been pretty and i know we
could argue all day over whether or not
avatar the last airbender is anime or
not
technically it's not anime is animation
that's produced out of japan
avatar was made in the united states so
it would be more correct to say that
it's western animation that's done in
the style of anime
and one of the hallmarks of some of the
previous netflix live-action anime
adaptations have been
very quick and dirty productions but
most of that content is stuff that they
just buy
out of japan so japan produces a lot of
really
janky looking live-action adaptations of
anime
most of the time netflix will just
license that one of the first
really authentic netflix original anime
live-action adaptations is actually
going to be the one
piece series i've got a lot of questions
about that i haven't seen any concept
art i don't know if it's going to be
terrible or if it'll be good who knows
and even though there are a lot of
people now that are making m night
shyamalan last airbender live action
movie jokes
things have not gotten that bad yet the
difference between what happened
then with that movie and what's
happening now with the live-action
series
is that when they were making the
live-action movie mike and brian said
that they barely got
any input at all during the making of
that
in netflix despite evidence that the
contrary aren't complete idiots they
know how much everyone hates the
live-action last airbender movie
and most of them probably understand the
reasons why everyone hates it so i don't
think that
even though mike and brian won't be
directing episodes or overseeing
creative anymore
that the new series will just turn into
another m night level disaster
but right now what's happening is the
series has not been cancelled at all
they're still going to make it
but because of the leadership changes
behind the scenes my assumption is
they won't try to start casting and
filming it till early next year
meaning the earliest they'd be able to
release it would be the end of 2021 next
year or spring 2022
it just depends on how fast they can get
into production so hopefully netflix
doesn't cut too many corners or cheap
out on it but a lot of you asked now
mike and brian said that they're going
to continue working on new avatar
universe material there are a lot of
new comic books and new books that
they've been publishing in the avatar
universe
but the odds of them doing a new
animated series with another avatar just
probably shot up a thousand percent
nickelodeon still owns the property the
classic animated series was the most
popular show
in the world on netflix for a long time
this year so demand
for new avatar material is through the
roof if they're moving through the
avatar cycle with their different series
the next avatar that they do whether it
be said in the past or set in the future
with a new avatar
would be an earthbender avatar now a lot
of you know that they actually just
published a big avatar kyoshi book
she is one of the most hardcore avatars
in the history of the universe
she's like the stabby avatar that's not
afraid to kill people
in fact in the new kiyoshi book there's
actually a story about how she defeated
a warlord
by bending the water in his body
freezing it to ice
stopping his heart that is straight up
hardcore that is not something that you
would catch aang or even korra doing
and if you haven't read that book it's
actually pretty solid it's available
right now there are two parts i believe
there's going to be another
third part to that that they'll make
pretty soon too and if you're looking
for more avatar inspired animation
the dragon prince series on netflix is
actually made by a lot of og
avatar people the creator of the series
is actually aaron e haas who is the
original
head writer on avatar the last airbender
i will continue to make more avatar the
last airbender videos so leave all your
video requests
in the comments below but click here to
learn about what the supposed story of
avatar the last airbender season 4
would have been and click here for my
brand new stranger things
season 4 trailer video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!